hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to huniepop now by
popular demand and surprisingly you guys
really love this series and I actually
had a lot of fun playing it I'm gonna be
playing it some more but not to the
point where people said that there are
actual sex scenes in this game and
there's actual nudity so be warned
you're not gonna see much in the way of
boob lose other than what you see in
front of you right now I am like 12
years old who calls him boo-boo lose God
what's wrong with me anyway so I'm gonna
be playing again and also people said
that I was playing badly and I don't
know what you're talking about I am a
master of love I'm ready to serve these
women a big heaping helping of marking
love and they hurt and kind of run away
screaming cuz that doesn't sound good at
all but I'm gonna talk with them and I'm
gonna flirt with them and it's gonna be
a lot of fun for probably me not them
for your degree in Business
Administration
did you know I find that so interesting
what's cooking good-looking hey I'm the
one with the corny pickup lines
do you prefer one season of the exact
opposite of what you like no just my
adoring fans in the hope that I don't
disappoint them it could have been an
engineer anyway the idea of seeing your
beautiful face once
nice no it's not at all yeah that was a
boy okay I didn't mean to do that so
anyway you can actually check their
profile I can see what food they like
breakfast and fruits which is what
people told me that I wasn't doing I was
being stupid and I can buy her pancakes
I bet she likes that muffins
and fruits I hope those get replenished
every day because otherwise I'm gonna be
in a lot of stuff this in your face
exactly fruit shoved into your gob no
that's like my nickname it's not but
okay we're gonna pretend it is uh-huh
shall we go match three for some odd
reason in some odd place I think we
shall I don't even remember I went on a
date with Lowell in the last episode
sorry I blacked out for a little bit
there I don't know what happened I just
Jesus oh man I gotta play this with my
eyes closed kids don't look you can't
see this it's too much sure you can see
people being blown up and eviscerated
and blood everywhere
but boobs how dare you okay try to be
mature adults here okay so someone also
said that I need to get my passion level
off before I do anything because that's
what increases my combo like I have to
do that first and therefore I will get
passion levels up higher and then be
able to do what I need to do so I need
to get those passion levels up also the
bells do do turns but I didn't know that
I just didn't do that
there we go passion level up okay that's
good movie date for the next one but now
we've got Connor she likes affection oh
she loves affection I am having trouble
looking away from you lady my god that
is the weirdest bikini I've ever seen
but oddly I think it's my favorite all
of a sudden I have no idea why but I
suddenly suspect that I enjoy this very
much this game is the best I love this
game anymore sentiment to be able to do
what you need I'm great just wait till
you see how good I never mind
damnit I'm gonna lose this one titties I
know I say that normally but now it
seems inappropriate when I say that
poopy yeah that's good to sanity you
absolutely don't worry my reply the love
some reason I don't know why so if I do
this oh that did absolutely screwed
everything up I'm the worst the worst of
the worst them I'm the worst worst ever
so close to love
oh so close to love there was like all
these red I could have calm Road but I
didn't
I'm a loser the perpetual loser
god I need like the moon's cuz the moons
give eat nah man if I got I still
wouldn't have enough I need twenty-one
to go back oh god I'm so bad at love
failure I know because the stupid hearts
W I would have been fine I am a God of
love I love well that was a thing
Lucy's nightclub okay okay bye sorry
about the horrible mix-and-match date I
didn't mean to embarrass myself that
much but I'm glad you love them is oh
hey how's it going can you loosen your
voice up a little holy crap
you look like you'd rather be anywhere
else than talking to me I feel your pain
why are you here exactly no no that's
why I'm talking to you I can't stand
these other girls
someone coming back over here oh sorry
but I guess you can keep me company so
my friend is ready
you won't regret coming back you're
talking to me I swear you won't regret
it
cool are you doing are you doing yeah oh
yeah give me them who knees
I couldn't agree more yeah maybe even
ask you less but I just asked it I
literally it's the second time I opened
my mouth to you that sounded weird but I
can make it weirder if you want you just
wasn't
I got a porno mag you want to eat that
no there's no food left what kind of
food does she like what are you not me
what do you who you wouldn't you like
candy and desserts you like those right
stuff that in your face just like you're
not gonna regret talking to me cuz I
like the great list let's go win some
stupid [ __ ] are you wearing pajamas
the games here figured out cool I don't
I don't know how to do what I'm doing
here how do you like one of these I know
nice little bit
I'm gonna win this one
good yeah you're welcome
I gave that to everyone else but it
really is special when I give it to you
Oh God only four moves left how do I get
down to this many moves I thought I had
more than that my pride more oh that
hurt my heart why do you need to be so
cruel okay thanks yeah video games
especially fighting games an online a
memos all right what do you got ask Oh
kinds old school of latest consoles and
games you see my six set up not really
nothing like the classics
FPS I don't even know what the word bro
means what are you talking about bread
okay I'm not a gamma go now I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go to the shopping mall at
midnight No have a good one cuz
apparently your friend wasn't in the
nightclub anymore she was at the mall I
was Tuesday I didn't even sleep alright
then no [ __ ] my hair isn't dried out
you need to turn around and walk away
please I won't have to look at your
[ __ ] face she has to know you're in
charge and her [ __ ] isn't going to
face
I've been known to get a little stupid
from time to time hmm yes I've known
I've been known to smoke some dank buoys
in my in my time you want to go back to
my place and smoke some weeds no you
want I love you okay so anyway that's
enough for this episode of huniepop boys
it was an eventful one filled with
failure I can't wait to continue that
streak forever and ever so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
dig this I'm having a blast playing it
and as always I will see you in the next
video